foreign
[Music]
the Demeter on Charter from Romania to
London
shipping private crates
tense unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
foreign
man University of Cambridge I know my
way around the boat our Charter has
agreed to pay a bonus for timely arrival
in London
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
US clear
[Applause]
livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it drinks our blood
call him Dracula
he's coming
you see the size of that bloody thing
[Music]
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]
oh